[Music]
it has been a crazy week in America
let's find out what happened
President Biden invited the Atlanta
Braves to the White House this week to
celebrate their World Series win and to
ask them to change their racist ass logo
the EPA will create a new office that
merges the offices of environmental
justice civil rights and conflict
prevention and here's what it'll look
like
wind water fire heart
foreign
Fashion Week started on Tuesday and will
showcase collections from 107 Brands
said my Grandmama I can get that same
stuff at TJ Maxx
NASA's so-called Dart spacecraft
intentionally slammed into an asteroid
this week in the first ever test of a
planetary defense system which frankly
is insane huh it's just like the movie
Armageddon yeah yes scientists say that
they're still waiting to determine if
the impact actually affected the
trajectory of the asteroid but it's
still very cool wait
they don't know if it worked I mean I'm
sure we'll find out in a few weeks but
no not yet
I understand
what do you mean don't try to stop me
all right Amber it's hard enough as it
is
what are you talking about we both know
how important you are to this show
I'm gonna have to go up there and blow
that thing up myself why
you just said makes any
Amber you're right thank you Wally
tarek's way too important to the show
I'll do it do what I'll bring a nuclear
bomb up to the asteroid and blow it and
me to Smithereens Wally we are not
sending you to space to blow up an
asteroid why would we send you because
it's easier to teach a cute card guy to
be an astronaut than it is to teach an
astronaut how to be a cue card guy that
is objectively not true besides we need
you here
we can't do the show without cue cards
of course we can't thank you Jenny but
you can do it without a head writer oh
Jesus
Amber the show's already written my work
here is done all I need now is a space
shuttle a hydrogen bomb and a pack of
smokes since when do you smoke
since I found out today's the day I'm
gonna die okay that's it you guys nobody
is gonna sacrifice themselves to blow up
this asteroid that's not how it works
and it isn't even headed towards Earth
oh you're disappointed of course we are
why who doesn't love a surprise day off
okay all right you know what never mind
back to the monologue
the pop song Barbie Girl recently turned
25 years old and then Leonardo DiCaprio
took it off his playlist
[Applause]
Buckingham Palace this week revealed the
Royal Cipher of King Charles III if you
haven't seen it it looks like this
how dark will the baby be
[Applause]
me
[Music]
oh
Dr Tom Hanks will release his debut
novel next May and then his son chat
will translate it into Patois
life be like a box of chocolates
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right
it's good it's good according to a new
study unnecessary meetings cost
companies as much as 100 million dollars
each year in less productivity for more
on this let's Circle back next week
finally
1415 students at the University of
California Irvine broke a Guinness World
Record last week by playing a game of
red light green light there were no
survivors
foreign
[Applause]
we're off to a good start tonight but we
have so many more things to talk about
like Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker
I know right
Walker was in the news this week after
it was reported that he may have
exaggerated the amount of money he
donated to non-profit charities this
wouldn't be the first time Walker has
been accused of exaggerating or flat out
lying now hold on a minute
what who said that I did ah no it's
Herschel Walker everybody
hey it's Herschel Walker everybody they
know I just said that
Herschel what are you doing here as a
person running for the office of
politician for the great state of
Atlanta I felt the need to come here to
confront these horrible alligators and
the harbor alligators that the people
have made against me you mean
allegations
what'd I say
alligators
you say tomato I say Clamato okay
okay no what doesn't make sense is how
people keep calling me a liar like
George Washington DC said I can never
tell a lie
[Applause]
there's so much wrong with that
statement No what's wrong is how the
fake media is portraying me I don't
exaggerate and I don't lie there's not a
lion bone in my body and I show I should
know because I'm a doctor
you're a doctor yeah just last week I
successfully removed the wishbone in an
operation at a hospital in Hasbro that's
a board game
oh I was hardly bored I was enthralled I
was enthralled by the buzzing red nose
of my satisfied patient now look down
but you aren't going to trick me this is
nothing but speculation and hairspray
you mean hearsay
you say potato I say gelato that is very
long
what's very wrong is how the FBI raided
Mar-A-Lago that would have never
happened when I was an agent you were
never an FBI agent oh yeah where did I
get this that's a punch card from Baskin
Robbins
[Applause]
I'm two punches away from becoming head
of sprinkles
Mr Walker this is embarrassing no
what's embarrassing is President Biden
canceling student loan debt when I
graduated from the University of Georgia
I made sure to pay off all my loans
without a government handout you
graduated from the University of what
Georgia the University of what Georgia
you know you're saying it wrong no it
was George I take the midnight train
there all the time
Mr Walker didn't you leave college early
to play football professionally
Classics being from the woke me up
before you go go mob
but just like Trump can declassify with
his mind I can graduate with mine and
that's once a Groupon you mean one to
grow on
hey you say tomato I say Rachel Maddow
get out of here Herschel Walker
everybody
[Applause]
hang on
why was he carrying a football uh what
was the football for it's his like
security blanket oh that's nice
Governor Ron DeSantis has faced
criticism recently for flying immigrants
from Texas to Martha's Vineyard these
immigrants have reportedly been lied to
about housing and work opportunities and
have been sent across the country by
DeSantis as a publicity stunt he has
used these vulnerable people to try to
gain voters and when I heard about it it
made me so mad that I wanted to roast
him but he deserves worse than that he
deserves to be read for Filth and he
deserves to have it done by an expert
which brings us to a segment called an
Exquisite drag by an Exquisite drag
[Music]
Ron DeSantis you sent in Clan Hood
flying people was your big idea you
probably booked that [ __ ] on spirit
because you have the spirit of old ass
racist from a Quentin Tarantino film
actually I bet you booked that [ __ ] on
Frontier
because that's a whole new frontier of
stupidity
you are so racist that you probably hate
your own last name
okay
let's get Petty
you look like God Smiley had a love
child with a Weeble wobble
you look like Tom Holland after he was
found at the bottom of the river
you look like you couldn't lift a gallon
of milk yet milk is the only thing you
drink
I have no way to prove this but I am
confident in saying that you don't wash
your hands when you pee
you look like the term basic [ __ ] came
to life it was raised by bigots
that are probably kissing cousins
you look like a missionary both the
person and the sexual position
[Applause]
you are such a gigantic [ __ ]
that if you posted your face on Grindr
it would be considered two obscene
[Applause]
you hack ass whack ass no Talent no
policy having [ __ ] ass Bernie cross
come to life
[ __ ] I hope you get covered in your
booty hole anyway
[Music]
jiggly
everyone catch jiggly in Translation on
out TV and on drag race Philippines on
wall presents Plus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]